what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today
I will be breaking down the latest
events in the seven deadly sins story
including the return of some fan
favorite characters and the new
developments in the intense battle
against the demon king including the
demon King's new demon king Cotulla form
we're also going to be discussing why
Zell drous is a true man of culture and
lots of other crucially important things
so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the seven deadly sins
content on this channel you want to see
more please leave a like to let me know
it really helps and if you haven't to be
new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification
barrel to turn on all notifications you
can also check me out on Twitter and
Instagram
at anime uproar for all the latest seven
deadly sins news and updates and finally
this video will of course contain manga
spoilers for the seven deadly sins story
we are dealing with the latest
developments in the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned chapter 330 begins where the
previous chapter left off with the
commandments finally leaving Zelda's
body after zelgius managed to spank his
daddy back in the spirit world as
zelgius regains his body and his normal
kawaii form the demon king tries to
force the commandments back into his
son's body
however bond quickly uses snatch to take
sell just out of the path of the demon
king and both gelda and zelgius are
grateful to bond for moving Zell drous
out of harm's way
meliodas congratulate his brother for
overcoming the demon king then meliodas
proceeds to comment on what we've all
been thinking
Zelda's tendency to just stick his face
right inside gaol does ample bosom I
mean I commented on this before zel
dress really does like those vampire
jiggles and don't get me wrong I'm not
judging I'm not judging at all but it is
pretty funny that zelgius does this type
of stuff in the middle of an epic battle
against what is probably the final boss
in the entire series I actually think of
these cute and funny moments between
Zelda's and gelda are meant to
underscore the evolution of Zell dress
as a character when he was first
introduced zelgius was always fierce and
angry and he is obsessed with the idea
of maintaining a strong reputation as
the
to the demon king when we first met Zell
drous we never would have imagined him
in such a position smiling and blushing
while resting his face in his
girlfriend's cleavage but the more we
learned about Zell dress as the story
has progressed the more we realized that
there is a lot more to him than it first
appears zelgius was not just an obedient
follower of the demon king he was in
love with gelda something his father's
strongly disapproved of and he wanted to
become the demon king not to continue
his father's regime but to change it for
the better I have to say that I really
come around to love Zell dress as a
character even though he was introduced
pretty late in the series the zelgius
has grown developed and I feel like he's
now become a fan favorite and I mean who
wouldn't appreciate a fellow oppai
connoisseur and a true man of culture
like zelgius while celtris is busy with
Galdos bosoms the 10 commandments fly up
into the air then suddenly they
dispersed all over britannia and they
begin to infect the land the wildlife
and everything else around them like
some evil oil spill even merlin the
person who knows the most about magic in
the entire group looks visibly concerned
when she sees what is happening the
commandments begin to take over
everything around them like a dark
disease and everything from rocks and
Hills to animals and plants are quickly
consumed by the commandments
Merlin explains that now that he has
been rejected by his two sons and their
bodies the demon king has decided to
make the very ground of britannia into
his new vessel man you really have to
give it to the demon king this guy is
nothing if not stubborn and persistent
he fought me Liotta's bond and wild in
purgatory he took over melioidosis body
then he took over zelgius his body and
he still refuses to give up the demon
king is determined to destroy all of
britannia if he has to which is of
course something that the sins
desperately want to avoid so this
strategy of polluting the land with the
commandments is definitely something
that the sins cannot take lightly
we then see the demon king take
everything he absorbed through the
commandments and transform it into a
massive and I mean massive Lovecraftian
monster this is basically nanatsu
Cthulhu a terrifying creature that is as
big as a large Mount
as we come to terms with just how
massive the demon King's new insane form
has become we suddenly switch
perspectives and see our boy the best
boy Hawk sama and our girl the best girl
Hawks momma approaching the site of the
epic battle puck makes a silly joke
about turning back when they see the
giant monster and all the ominous
thunder and lightning but we all know
that he's just messing with us because I
am sure that by now Hawk samus power
level is so high that it makes even
ultimate Eskin or look like James from
Team Rocket anyway
everyone in Britannia is freaking out
pretty hard about what is happening
including Jenna and nari the holy
Knights in King's Bartra the Giants and
fairies everyone is afraid that the
demon King's new form will either
consume or destroy the entire kingdom
the Cthulhu demon king is once again
engaged in his usual self aggrandizing
rambling he tells everyone to tremble
and fear and accept their deaths because
no one can defy the demon king and get
away with it
etc etc at this point I think that this
type of ranting is just a normal Tuesday
night for the demon king the demon king
is wondering why the sins are not
trembling and why instead of feeling
afraid and hopeless they actually look
confident the ant says that she is not
afraid because all her friends are here
King says that he is not afraid because
he has a wedding to plan
and go there you know what I'm not going
to even try to understand what Golder
said I am NOT a licensed psychiatrist
Merlin a scanner and bond are also
confident or at least they appeared to
be and Merlin suggests that the demon
King's decision to try to use Britannia
as a vessel was just a move made out of
desperation meliodas looks confident as
well and he is ready to take on the
demon king in his new Cthulhu form along
with his fellow sins featuring of course
Elizabeth gelda and Zell drous and last
but not least we cannot forget Hawke and
Hawkes mama why do you guys think that
the sins look so confident clearly they
can sense that the great one the Prince
of power Hawke sama is approaching the
battlefield everything up to this point
was nothing but a warm-up for the return
of the inner scale of seven deadly sins
the one and only Hawke seriously though
as far as we know Hawke and hawks mama
had been in purgatory
and time passes much more slowly there
than in the real world with that said it
is quite possible that they have
unlocked some new form of power or some
new hidden knowledge that will end up
being useful in the current battle after
all if this wasn't the case then why
would naka bouzouki have Hawke and
Hawkes maman go to purgatory and then
reappear at this exact moment if they
didn't have any role to play in the
actual battle they could have just met
up with the sins after the demon king
was already defeated as you know if
you've been watching my 7 Deadly Sins
videos over the last few months I have
said multiple times that Hawk Hawks mama
and King Arthur will make an appearance
during this battle Hawk and Hawks mama
are just about to join the fray and I
still think that we are going to see
Arthur again in some capacity I also do
hope that we will see the supreme deity
at some point but right now I honestly
don't know since it's been so long since
we've heard anything about her at any
rate I do have to give some props to the
demon king I've seen quite a few people
say that they weren't very impressed
with him as a villain but to his credit
he is insanely persistent every time he
faces a setback you just find some new
way to spice things up and keep on
fighting it's true that at some point
and fairly soon by the look of it the
demon king will have to fall this battle
can't keep going on forever and the more
characters we see gathering to fight the
demon king together the more likely it
is that he will be defeated sometime
soon but with that said I would still
like to see the supreme deity make a
sudden appearance and change the game up
yet again
maybe the supreme deity and the demon
king can form a temporary alliance in
order to subdue their rebellious
children and that would definitely turn
this battle up a few more notches
ultimately this is a battle shown and so
of course our heroes will win out in the
end but getting the supreme deity
involved and having her be defeated
along with the demon king would open the
door for both Mele Otis and Elizabeth to
become the new leaders of their
respective clans and they could then use
those positions to finally bring about
peace between the demons and the
goddesses if they can defeat the demon
king but the supreme deity is still just
chilling inside the celestial realm
without ever having to actually fight
anyone then it's kind of hard for us to
see how the story
can be resolved from what we know so far
the supreme deity seems to be just as
responsible as the demon king for the
holy war and all the pointless pain and
suffering it has caused over the course
of thousands of years we know from the
behavior of people like Ludo Chell that
the goddess leadership has serious
hatred and aggression issues to put it
mildly so the idea of letting the
supreme deity just continue with
business as usual seems a bit illogical
if you were to ask me to be objective
and tell you what I think will happen
next
I would say that from a narrative
perspective the supreme deity needs to
appear and some form of resolution needs
to occur surrounding her as well if that
does happen we could be looking at
twenty more chapters or so before the
series ends although to be honest the
fact that it's taken this long for the
supreme deity to become relevant kind of
makes me second-guess myself like maybe
knock of a suzuki we'll just have her
keep chilling in the celestial realm
while all this stuff is happening in
Britannia we'll have to wait and see but
I'm definitely excited to see what is
going to happen next let me know what
you guys think are you happy to see the
glorious return of Hawk and Hawks mama
and do you think that they gained some
new form of power or some new important
knowledge while they were away if so
what do you think that this knowledge or
power might be finally how about our
boys eldress a true WOM and respecter
and appreciator well done my friend
well done if you enjoyed this video you
want to see more $0.70 content right
here on the channel please leave a like
to let me know and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications remember
that you have to make sure that you
turned on all notifications if you want
to see our videos if you don't YouTube
will bury them you can also follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest seven deadly sins
news and updates I want to give a big
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons who make videos like this one
possible special thank you to all of our
pro hero to your patrons including the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings eldress on hell
cruise stealers poet Pablo atropos
Wraith very dolla beat a karate GN
Anatole Cassatt's ki DJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and I can't forget the ones
that rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons including Ingrid ah
Alan Adam Matty Mac makoto-kun and yeah
boys Seth if you enjoy our videos and
you think that they add some value to
your life consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]